ces professeurs de paix s du lycée 17
mar joue peut être le match le plus
important de leur carrière à brassard
noir autour du bras ils ont organisé ce
mardi 5 juin une veillée funèbre
objectif protester contre la suppression
de l'option sport dans leur
établissement la rentrée 2010 9 voulue
par l'éducation nationale on pouvait pas
se permettre de rien faire parce qu'on
pense à nos élèves on pense aussi à
notre équipe de direction qui nous a
toujours soutenus au niveau du projet
d'établissement
on pense à tous et on pense à on pense à
tous les parents qui sont aussi investir
la spécialité instauré depuis 1999 par
l'établissement permet aux élèves
d'ajouter cinq heures de sport en plus
par semaine en second des quatre en
première et en terminale
cette année près d'une centaine d'élèves
ont choisi cette option donc un vrai
gâchis parce que je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient mesure est un petit peu là le la
perte
la perte et l'expérience que ça peut
apporter aussi bien pour accéder à une
filière staps pour les élèves qui
sortent avec le bac ou pour des
simplement pour leur épanouissement
personnel l'enrichissement pour pour le
bac pour les points que ça peut apporter
au mac
d'autres actions pourraient être menées
dans les prochaines semaines le match
n'est peut-être pas encore terminée